ce sont des images que les russes
n'avaient plus vu depuis le début de la
pandémie de comics 19 dans ce
supermarché de moscou l'heure n'est pas
à la pénurie mais il ya des rayons vides
le sucre la farine manque les moscovites
font des provisions je voulais prendre
un kilo de sucre au moins kg je pense
que les gens paniquent et ils prennent
tout ce qu'ils peuvent c'est vraiment
pas une bonne chose un peu plus de trois
semaines après les premières sanctions
occidentales
l'économie russe n'est pas à terre mais
elle vacille le rouble a perdu un quart
de sa valeur
conséquence les secteurs basé sur les
importations souffre chez ce caviste et
des prix des bouteilles de vin française
par exemple ont explosé
là c'est du château mouton rothschild
culte tout est toujours plus cher là les
prix a augmenté de 50 %
des tarifs qui s'envolent chaque jour un
peu plus et qui ne laisse même pas le
temps à ivan gontcharov de changer ces
étiquettes de prix alors il les a tout
simplement retirés des rayons elles sont
toutes dans le sac on les a enlevées
exprès
c'est très inquiétant les affaires ne
vont vraiment pas bien on a peur que la
boutique faire
face aux difficultés les entrepreneurs
russes tentent de s'adapter à togliatti
dans le sud lusine automobile avtovaz
anticipe une pénurie des composants
électroniques qu'elle importe pour ne
pas placer ses salariés au chômage
technique elle vient de leur annoncer
que leurs trois semaines de vacances
estivales étaient déplacés au mois
d'avril
moi ça m'arrange pas
faire ça votre accord
nos patrons essaie de trouver une
solution pour comme reste pas son
travail
en russie les économistes s'attendent à
des mois difficiles dans ses dernières
prévisions la banque centrale russe a
indiqué que le pib du pays pourrait
chuter d'au moins 8% en 2022